hi
my name is ryan and i'd like to show you
around the google cloud console where
you can manage your google cloud
resources directly from the web
in the next few minutes we'll explore
several key areas of the console that
can help you as you begin your journey
with google cloud
ready let's get started
[Music]
google cloud resources are the
fundamental components that make up
google cloud services
these may include compute engine virtual
machines cloud storage buckets cloud sql
database instances and more
resources are organized hierarchically
using projects and folders
projects are how you group resources
together and are the first level of the
hierarchy all resources must belong to
exactly one project so a given compute
engine virtual machine or a cloud
storage bucket would belong to one
project
optionally projects can belong to
organizations which provide centralized
visibility and control across all
projects in a given org an organization
helps administrators for your company or
group manage billing or security across
many projects you can further organize
your company's departments or teams into
folders folders can contain projects and
also subfolders for further structure
and nesting
when you open console.cloud.google.com
here's the landing page dashboard
at the top you can see which google
cloud project you're currently viewing
you can click the project name to switch
to a different project
if you do so you'll see the resources
for your other project
you can also create a new project right
here
another key area of the console is the
left navigation menu located in the top
left corner
this menu helps you access your google
cloud services
for example if you navigate to the cloud
storage section you can create new cloud
storage buckets upload objects and
download objects you can also pin your
favorite products to the top for easy
access
i'll pin storage to make sure i can
quickly get to my buckets next time
next up we have the search bar which
allows you to quickly search for google
cloud products resources and
documentation
for example you could search for the
name of one of your other projects if
you want to switch to it
if you search for cloud run you'll see
links to the cloud run section of the
console
documentation and tutorials related to
cloud run and a list of cloud run
related apis that you might want to
manage
the home dashboard provides a high level
overview of your google cloud project
giving you information about key metrics
billing and getting started guides
the dashboard is customizable allowing
you to show hide and reorder the
different cards how you want
there's also the activity stream which
shows you information about all the
activities happening across your google
cloud resources in one place
for example you can see which projects
have been updated
what your teammates are doing or audit
access to your google cloud resources
next is the apis and services section
where you can do things like enable or
disable apis
view api usage information and manage
credentials
if you click enable apis and services at
the top you'll be brought to the api
library
this is where you can view information
about the hundreds of different google
cloud apis across areas like maps
machine learning google workspace and
more
if you click on cloud vision api you'll
be brought to the cloud vision api page
where you can click enable to enable the
api this allows you to use the vision
api in your applications
if you ever get stuck the support
section is also accessible right from
the navigation menu
you can get help via chat over the phone
or from other community members
there are several different support
offerings that you can compare and
contrast to see what makes the most
sense for you
another key part of the console is cloud
identity and access management or cloud
iam
here you can manage and create
permissions for your google cloud
resources
as your team grows you can grant access
to teammates in cloudiam
you can add users groups or service
accounts and assign them any number of
roles to grant them the permission they
need
for example you can add your friend
james as an editor for your google cloud
project
next up we have cloud shell which
provides you with command line access to
your cloud resources directly from your
web browser
powered by a small virtual machine with
persistent disk space it comes
pre-installed with helpful tools like
the google cloud sdk docker git and
various programming languages
this makes it easy to get started and
explore google cloud without having to
download additional software to your
local device
there's also cloud shell editor which
makes it easy for you to write code
directly from your web browser and
deploy it to the cloud
the billing section of the console is
where you can manage billing accounts
and link your projects to them
a cloud billing account defines who pays
for a given set of google cloud
resources
to use google cloud services you must
have a valid billing account linked to
your google cloud projects
the billing account can be linked to
payment methods like the free trial a
credit card or a bank account
there are also interactive quick start
experiences available in the console
these tutorials which you can find on
the home dashboard in the getting
started section
guide you through how to accomplish
essential tasks with different cloud
products
for example this tutorial guides you
through how to create a cloud storage
bucket upload a file to the bucket and
delete the bucket
and you can do this all in under five
minutes
beyond the web portal the google cloud
console is also available on android and
ios mobile apps
you can use these to monitor and manage
your google cloud applications on the go
so there you have it an overview of what
the google cloud console is and how you
can get started
make sure to check out the other
episodes of google cloud essentials
where we cover the google cloud sdk the
free trial key use cases and more
i can't wait to see what you built with
google cloud
[Music]
[Music]